I want to do the same problem
that I did in the last video.
But I want to show you
that there's multiple ways
to solve these problems that
should hopefully give you
the right answer if you
do them in the right way.
So once again, one
pipe can fill a pool
1 and 1/2 times faster
than a second pipe.
If both pipes are open, the
pool can be filled in 6 hours.
If only the slower
pipe is open, how long
would it take to fill the pool?
So as I said in the last video,
whenever you do these problems,
it's very important to
think in terms of rate.
The rate at which
the slower pipe
can fill a pool and the
rate at which the faster
pipe can fill a pool.
Right over here,
I'm going to define
that the slower pipe
can fill a pool in r.
So its rate is r pools per hour.
So if its rate is r pools
per hour-- and r for rate--
what is the faster pool's rate?
The faster pool's rate is
going to be 1.5 times r.
It's 1 and 1/2 times faster.
It has 1 and 1/2 times the rate.
So it's going to be able
do 1.5r pools per hour.
And what's their combined rate?
Well, you can add the rates.
r plus 1.5r-- let me
write this in orange--
so if you say their combined
rate is r plus 1.5--
what am I doing-- plus
1.5r pools per hour,
which is equal to
2.5r pools per hour.
And they're also telling us
that their combined rate,
if both pipes are open, the
pool can be filled in 6 hours.
So they're telling
us that the combined
rate is 1 pool in every 6 hours.
So they're saying that
the combined rate is also
equal to 1 pool in every 6
hours or 1/6 of a pool per hour.
1 pool in every 6 hours
is the same thing--
so that's this line right over
here-- 1 pool in every 6 hours
is the same thing as
1/6 of a pool per hour.
And then, once again, we
have 2.5r is equal to 1/6.
We can multiply both sides.
So let me do it this way.
We can multiply both sides by 6.
Let me just rewrite it so
I have some real estate.
2.5r.
The units are the
same on both sides,
so really this needs
to be equal to this.
So 2.5r needs to
be equal to 1/6.
You can multiply
both sides by 6.
This just becomes 1.
This right over here,
6 times 2.5 is 15.
So you get 15r is equal to
1 or r is equal to 1/15.
And let's see how
that might make sense.
So we know that the slower
pool is r pools per hour.
Or we could say it
is 1/15 of a pool.
1/15 of a pool per hour.
Or you could view it as to do
one pool, it takes 15 hours.
So once again, to answer our
question, if only the slower
pipe is open, how
long would it take?
15 hours.
So once again, the
exact same problem we
did in the last video,
just a different way.
And frankly, a
little bit simpler.
Although, I went into a
little bit more detail
in the last video
so I don't know
if I can make that comparison.